did you get a chance to say goodbye to  Stanley at all the guy who created this  whole universe the one of the last times  I saw him we were shooting Civil War and  his cameo that day was he's I think a  UPS delivery man exactly he had a great  line he goes I have a package for Tony  stank what did you say to him did you I  mean I assumed you'd met him before but  yeah was that the last time you saw him  that was one of the last times I saw him  and the crazy thing was he said that on  the first take he nailed it they go  alright resetting let's do it again  and after that he started saying I have  a package Robert and I said oh my god  it's wild even the guy who created the  character thinks of me in a moment where  he's talking about the character and go  this is so meta  Stanley is forgetting Who I am in this  moment